[Music]
okay
so let's play something very offbeat i
feel like playing something offbeat
um if we're playing white we'll play a
queen's gambit but yeah
okay so we're gonna play e5 and guess
what we're going to play guys
yeah i was considering going for the
latvian but let's play the elephant
gambit and
i or we can play the stafford you know
let's put the stafford let's play the
staffer no no let's play the stafford
in honor of my boy eric let's play the
staff at the yeah he doesn't take see i
was worried about that move
yeah damn boo boo
[Music]
okay
so let's make an offbeat opening out of
this don't worry don't despair i have an
idea
now
bishop c4 is i think not a very good
move we can we can take e4 but i'm a
little bit worried about doing that i'm
not sure what the theory is there
we could play knight c6 and transpose to
the italian but another interesting move
that we could make i plan to play the
elephant gambit on this move so guess
what
since his bishop is on c4 he literally
walks into a
favorable version of the elephant gambit
let's play d5 and then e4
let's go for this line
no bishop c4 is fine and i'm sure that
white is
objectively better here but this is like
an improved elephant gambit where
he's lost a couple of tempe and we get
all the moves we want to play anyway
knight g5 okay so he's already going to
be in trouble here pretty quickly this
is a mistake
i'm pretty sure so he's trying to play
it in the style of a fried liver and i
think he's not fully appreciating the
fact that the d5 pawn is blocking the
bishop so knight takes f7 is not a
serious threat and one important thing
to understand here is that knight takes
f7 king takes f7 d6 check may seem scary
but it only seems scary because that's a
discovered check discovered checks
aren't always scary we can just go
bishop e6 and he's going to run out of
attacking pieces
so what shall we do tempe h6 get out of
here
get out of g5 and he's got to drop back
to h3 and that's a very problematic move
now a lot of people let's wait for him
to go nih because i have a sense that he
might sacrifice on f7 i have a feeling
uh from the early
signs of how he's playing that he might
sack the knight
so we'll see
he's definitely contemplating it yeah
i'll explain knight takes d5 after the
game
you know he goes knight h3 okay good
so here there's an instructive moment
here
um
where a lot of players would immediately
grab this knight and ruin his king side
pawn structure and then play knight
takes d5 and that's good black is
probably better there
but you should always be looking for
ways to improve on the initial ideas you
come up with and that's a mentality that
masters and gm's have naturally
you never rush into an idea before even
after you've decided that that's the
direction you want to go in you're
always looking for ways to optimize
uh and improve uh the general idea
you've decided on there's a very nice
way of doing that here if you look at
his queen
it's his entire queenside is undeveloped
and so there exists the move bishop to
g4 now what's the idea
well his queen is trapped he has to
block that attack on the bishop and he
can do that in one of two ways the move
f3 exposes his position way too much we
just take that pawn and he can't take
back because he loses the knight and if
he plays bishop e2 well then we've
induced him into making his position
even more passive then we take the
knight and then we take on d5 and he
can't even trade that knight
and in addition we could take the d5
pawn with the queen if we wanted to
so it's not about winning the deep on
it's about making his position as
passive as possible um because the
d-pawn
we could we could have won it back
anyway
so you can see this is a simple way of
improving the position
f3 he plays okay wow
he plays f3
all right
that's pretty uh pretty crazy to me
because i think we're winning on the
spot
now bishop takes h3 would be an improved
version nonetheless of uh of this line
but we don't have to play bishop takes
h2 anymore this pawn on g2 is overloaded
so we play e takes f3 and i think he's
just totally lost here we're threatening
f takes g2 or threatening f to check
he has to take on f3 if i'm
understanding this correctly
and then we win a piece and his whole
his entire king side is in shambles
yeah this is totally game over
now as he's thinking i'm going to grab a
book that i have to show you
okay sorry
now he castles so here it's important to
be precise and as many of you are
indicating yes goodbye f2 goodbye queen
and it's over
okay so
one important point here don't rush into
taking this pawn prioritize development
why keep the king stranded in the center
the simplest is to play bishop e7 in
castle
and i i have yet to find a name for this
rule
but i would call this role relative
again this is all about prioritization
because
see
bishop c5 is a more active developing
move
but the priorities have shifted we no
longer need to make sure that every
piece is as active as possible the
priority now is on sheltering the king
so that we can get to down to the
business of just checkmating him right
and using our extra queen and bishop c5
would be slightly inaccurate due to
rookie one check and we'd have to move
the king and why bother with that when
you can guarantee the safety of the king
so knight 65 here would be a blunder
uh for what reason
and what should we do here how should we
develop in the most efficient way what
how do we
make sure that we don't let him live
here
he hangs the bishop bishop dave bishop
d5 queen d5 and rookie 7.
so instead we have two options we can go
knight d7 and then knight b6 and then
knight b takes d5 or
guess what now that we've castled we can
improve the activity of our pieces by
saying now we can play exactly curious
bishop c5 pinning the knight
uh and preparing all sorts of nasty
shenanigans like knight 4k that's great
well thank you for the trade and finally
now that we've unburdened ourselves
from
the bishop we can just play knight takes
d5 and finally we can win that pawn back
now not that we need that pawn that much
but it's a good idea because now we can
develop the other knight to c6 i'm
really nitpicking here we're up a queen
for god's sakes but
consider this like target practice when
you're up a queen practicing being as
precise as possible
is a very good idea because you know
that you're going to win the game anyway
and you can really cement good habits
when you're up material because the
stakes are relatively low you it's hard
to screw up
okay knight c6 uh develop the last piece
now notice that 95 is a pretty big sound
you know pretty big threat just to trade
off his bishop
yeah so let's go knight e5
yeah i think um
now obviously it is possible to lose a
game up a queen
and i have and many people have
but um
you know it
it's always a good idea to to work on
those habits because
the moment you start relaxing and the
bad habits creep in you're going to pay
the price for that
okay so rook f5 he's pinning the queen
what's the most efficient move here
thank you ace cuber for the prime what's
the most efficient way to win
thank you montana well
the pleasure is all mine no
you guys got debated knight f3 rook
takes f3
don't forget that the piece which is
being targeted in a discover check could
itself take the piece delivering the
discovered check that's something you
always have to check for no pun intended
so instead a much simpler move let's
play g6 and chase the rook away now
doesn't this weaken the king well he's
got no pieces to attack the king with so
that's not something we really care
about where should the queen go well c4
weakens the d4 square so we slide the
queen into d4 and the game is over we're
going to take b2 regardless of what he
does even if he takes the knight on e5
we take on b2 and this rook is the more
valuable one to take
yeah so i'm really nitpicking here but i
like taking this okay well also because
he kind of pre-moved
but um
you know that wins upon as well and it
ruins his entire queen side
well it's less about it being the
inactive rook it's more that thank you
hot mom yeah i was waiting for you to
gift this up the stream couldn't end
until you gifted that sub and it's more
about um about his just winning upon his
whole queen side being ruined
it doesn't matter well queen takes e5
knight c3 it it both options are totally
winning don't make a big deal out of
this it doesn't it really doesn't matter
okay i don't even care
so really quickly let's go over the game
now um
we were going for the stafford
unfortunately he deprived us of that
opportunity
again
i made a video on youtube on refuting
the stafford
you can take a look at it nonetheless i
think the stafford is a great weapon to
have in your pocket if you're 16 1700
eric does a phenomenal job of going over
the tricks
there's a lot of tricks
and
you know
and the refutation ends with wiping up a
full pawn for no compensation
white is not winning white is very
clearly better and you know for a gm it
would be unthinkable to risk playing a
line like this
but um
you know that certainly doesn't mean you
shouldn't have it in your pocket
i did not repeat it no okay
was my analysis wrong refutation uh is
again it i don't mean that condescending
i just busted the stafford like that
easily but
it you know a refutation relatively
speaking for a you know at a gm level it
would be considered a refuted line
you can absolutely still attempt it
which is why i wanted to play it here i
hope i've made that very clear and i
hope i made that clear in the video
itself that i'm not trying to like be
the party pooper
but relatively speaking there is a lot
more material on
gambits than playing against them and
that's something that i wanted to
redress
thank you mickey marsh for the prime
all right
so
he plays bishop c4 and i got a book
pretty recently called the exhilarating
elephant gambit
and the elephant gambit is e4 e5 knight
f3 d5 and it's one of those things that
fly under the radar it's considered to
be terrible and white is undoubtedly
better here white has many ways to get
an advantage
but it's you know it's very tricky
and this is a long book written by two i
think feed a masters who are pretty good
at analyzing stuff
and they come up with a lot of new ideas
for black i think their main
recommendation is the move bishop to d6
here there's also e4 but e4 i think has
been refuted completely
and
yeah john is right but bishop d6 is
quite interesting
and i would recommend it if you're
looking for
one of those things which you can pull
out once in a while if you want an
interesting and fun position nobody at
like a 17 1800 level is going to know
the best lines here
and if white plays it passively then you
can certainly get a combative
interesting type of position
okay so bishop c4 is very much possible
and here we can play knight c6 to
transpose into a fried liver but we
decided to go for like an improved
elephant gamut i think d5 is a very good
move actually
the latvian is completely refuted the
latvian is almost losing for black if i
remember correctly i don't quite
remember what the refutation is but i
think it definitely starts with 95 queen
f6
and
i think the old move knight c4 recently
made a comeback
but you'll have to check and i'll have
to check i'll probably do a video on it
sometime soon
so bishop c4
d5 he takes d5e4 and now a very big
mistake knight five this
straight off the bat puts white in
trouble i think the best idea would be
to go knight e5 as you do in the
elephant gambit bishop d6 d4
and odd passant is met with knight takes
d3
there's you know this is this is also
interesting for black black gets very
rapid development here this is a nice
bishop but
clearly not full compensation for the
pawn thank you mickey march for the
hundred
queenie two
is viable
yeah queen e2 is possible
but even here you could play bishop d6
and if white goes d3 saying ah well now
i've got you i've won the pawn
black can castle d takes c4 knight takes
e4 and it's always dangerous when you've
got these two pieces stacked
uh you've got to be super careful about
it all right
so that's the bottom line i'm not sure
what the best option is here you can
definitely analyze this with an engine
um but
that's uh that's that's all she wrote so
knight g5 h6
and yeah and now white is in big trouble
so knight f7 king f7 d6 jack
meets with bishop e6
and despite the fact that the king is on
e6 why does zero pieces develop so the
king can just walk back to f7 and you
could castle by hand
and knight h3 bishop g4 is a very
important move
so bishop e2 was relatively speaking the
only move bishop h3gh and i like taking
on d5 with either piece but i like
taking with the knight because that
opens up a pathway for the queen and
then knight could swing around to f4 but
after d3 white is okay
white is surviving here
black can maybe even go e3 trying to
sack the pawn to get this check in but
you know white can play white can
definitely play
white is alive
so
f3 ef is just game over i don't think he
has anything that he can do against the
combined threats of f2 and f takes g2
so
that's the end of the game here i mean
he has to he should have taken on f3 and
given up a piece
but the issue is that he his king is
also in huge trouble here on top of
everything else
so yeah that's uh
that's all she wrote
f2 knight f2 bishop d1 and the rest was
easy
all right you got it uh you got it
shadow
queen's game but it is
let's get one more in
okay and let's get a queen's gambit in
assuming he plays d5 yep we got a
queen's gambit
okay knight f6 so
this is important because a lot of
people play this move at this level this
is called the marshall
and it's not a good opening but white
has to be very precise otherwise you
actually could get up could end up in a
little bit of trouble
so why is this not a good move this is
like a cross between a grunfeld and a
queen's game but it declined
and that's just not how this works so
you take on
d5 and obviously the next move is super
clear you can play knight f3 first
that's one of the good moves but i'll
show you what i think is the best line
e4
and here's the thing that people should
remember
a lot of players go knight c3 in this
position because that looks very natural
right
knight c3 is a mistake it's a mistake
because and this is why the marshall can
be appealing to some players
and i only found this out pretty
recently when magnus played this against
me in a bunch of bullet games i kept
playing knight c3
black has what move
so good i'm glad you're this is an
important thing to learn
does anybody know why knight c3 is
inaccurate it's not c5 but you're close
it's not c5
it's e5 the move e5 is highly unpleasant
and i'll show you guys after the game
really quickly but e5 d takes e5 he
takes the queen with check
and either you take with the knight and
give up the e4 pawn or you take with the
king
the knight swings over to g4 you've lost
your castling rights and you're going to
lose back the extra pawn
whereas after knight c3 e5 d5
black can play well bishop b4 is not
possible there due to queen a4 but black
can just play bishop d6 and black is a
very nice position
so what you need to do here is play a
very hard move to find if you don't know
to play it bishop d3
so first of all you don't blunder the
pawn because of bishop b5 check
and the point is that it stops and takes
the sting out of e5 you just take on e5
and there's no queen trade possible so
you block uh you basically block the d
file so bishop d3 is the best way to get
an advantage
and now you have to continue playing
very carefully he plays g6
so
it's possible to just play knight f3
but
i'm not the biggest fan of allowing
bishop g4
which puts sort of gruenfeldesque
pressure on the d4 pawn so how should we
um how should we continue developing
here in the most circumspect fashion
a move that i don't always like to play
unless we have to
yeah so there's two possibilities 92 is
a very nice move 92
intending to meet bishop g4 with f3
that's totally good
but another good way of developing this
is a little bit more principled is to
play h3 and knight f3 you can afford to
do this because black's lost a bunch of
tempe with these knight d5 knight f6
moves so you can afford these types of
niceties
now we can play either knight c3 or we
can castle i don't think it really
matters
let's go knight c3
b6 now let's castle
and we've got a phenomenal position
we've got full central control
perfectly developed pieces we just got
one more thing left to develop and
that's the bishop on c1 where should we
put it
no need to reinvent the wheel here where
should we put the bishop
and one thing to get away to get out of
the way immediately e5 is not a good
move i talked about this yesterday so
you can check out the vid
but the movie 5 yields control of the d5
square and that's a pretty important
outpost for black these pawns get stuck
in mud
so you don't want to play e5 unless you
have a very specific follow-up
so there's two ways to develop the
bishop you can absolutely play bishop e3
here 100 3 bucks thank you so much
um
and
you can do it through the website and
and you can support the pawn but you
don't really need to because
the pawn already has the support of the
knight on f3 and if necessary you can
step back with this bishop and support
it with the queen so
i think bishop e3 is a little bit on the
passive side let's instead go to g5 and
put more pressure on his position
bishop f4 also very much possible
but there is a reason i chose bishop g5
over bishop f4 and i'll talk about that
afterward
yeah i mean there's a lot of good moves
here don't overthink this plenty of good
moves
it's it's not always necessary to obsess
over this stuff
okay
so
knight f to d7 that's clearly passive
but possible
but now there's many ways
to continue to continue the pressure
um
if you don't want to reinvent the wheel
if you don't want to reinvent the wheel
then the simplest is to go after this
bishop if we can eliminate this bishop
his king becomes weak he loses some of
the pressure on d4 so let's play queen
d2 and bishop h6 that's
very tried and true old reliable
perfectly good nothing wrong with
playing old reliable moves particularly
in such a dominant position so c5 now
our response here should be quite
obvious to people we certainly don't
want to take on c5 that justifies his
entire setup we want to go d5
stopping him from doing 95. so i see
what he's trying to do but
he's not going to be able to
uh to maintain the blockade over the
dark squares that he's trying to
establish
so i mean clearly we should take the
night
now it's interesting one interesting
thing that i think some
could benefit some people is is the
concept that
it's generally risky to move away from
when you fianchetto your bishop and you
move away
from its its home you venture out of the
square that you've created that can
involve a great deal of risk
because you could end up with a
situation when the bishop can't return
back to g7 and you've got all these
holes on the dark squares
and the bishop is susceptible to the
move f4 so what i would propose is to
first reposition the bishop to a6 to
make him regret it okay he comes back
but that gives us a very advantageous
trade he's giving us all the good stuff
here
we don't have to take on g7 there's no
rush but there's also no real need to
wait
because
we that's just another thing to worry
about i don't see a reason not to take
you know now there's many different
plans here we could absolutely go f4 we
could go after the kingside attack
but since we played one d4 i want to
play a little bit more positionally
and playing positionally doesn't just
mean like lame now we're gonna go after
him pretty quickly
but there's a couple of things left to
involve in the game and
neither rook is currently doing all that
much
now let's leave this rook on f1 because
who knows maybe we'll want to play f4
are fine the rook's going to come in
handy right but this rook can certainly
be doing a little bit more than it is
than it is
a lot of you are saying rook a to e1 but
here's the thing
i'm a little bit concerned that he's
going to play e6 and try to open up his
bishop
where would you want the rook to be
if he goes e6 and d takes c6 happens or
doesn't happen
you would want the rook to be on d1 rook
a to d1
stacking up with the queen okay so a6
let's accelerate the pace of our play a
little bit and now we have another
option and sky you proposed this on the
previous move let's do that now what
does he want he wants b5 what's the
drawback of b5 what pawn does it leave
undefended it leaves the c5 pawn
undefended and the king on g7 is already
vulnerable to checks along this diagonal
so who could propose a move that serves
two purposes it prevents b5 indirectly
and it gets this knight a little bit
more active the knight is just kind of
biting on granite not knight a4 we don't
need the knight there we go knight e2
so we're dragging the knight over to the
king side
where it could participate in an attack
and okay b5 is no longer dangerous he
could now play b5 and now the time has
come
for us to start king kingside operations
in earnest
so what should we do in what order
should we accomplish things
yeah let's go time for f4 we could have
also done queen g5
but f4 just seems a little bit more
direct
interesting alexander i i didn't realize
that i'll have to take a look but i
think bishop d3 is more accurate
but that's that's good to know uh we'll
take a look
no knights can bite on granite too
absolutely they can
okay
yeah so e6 now play this guy is good
he's fast and he's good now we have a
very pretty tactical idea
i'll begin with a check on c3 to drive
the king back
and now we have a very pretty tactic so
we have many possibilities here that
basically i think win the game we could
take on e6 and then slide the bishop
over to c oh actually that's not that's
even stronger sorry
i'll show you guys after the game a very
cool tactical idea that we
had instead
but what i'm seeing here is that after
d-e-f-e
his position is just starting to
collapse he's too passive he's incapable
of holding together
everything here we're attacking his pawn
and now because we've put the pawn on f4
what's going to be our follow-up
assuming that he plays rook a to e8
what's going to be our follow-up d6 was
the move yes
f5 f5 is going to come with a tremendous
effect we're just taking 96 his entire
position totally collapses here
so you can see it's like we played
pretty conservatively for a while
but when the time comes you step on the
gas pedal and
just because you're playing positionally
doesn't mean you can't win quickly and
doesn't mean you don't
resort to tactics when the time comes
yeah knight f5 was interesting
but i feel like this is just less yeah
it is less adventurous but
maybe less dangerous style
prepare slowly attack fast is always the
dictum 95 good move
good move but it's not going to help now
clearly we take with the bishop check
king g7 and now we have a crusher you
notice that the knight is pinned that's
the first thing to notice the second
thing to notice is that the king and the
queen are now on the same
uh on the same rank
and a very simple tactic comes in for
the win 57 thank you verbal for the
prime rook d7 is winning boom goes the
dynamite
the game is over
so just a little bit too passive by
black here that was his main problem he
was just not doing enough to prepare
himself for this kind of stuff
now by the way we would have done the
same thing had he played king h8 rook
takes queen
now everything the wheels come off and
he resigns very nice
so
according to alexander
grandmaster rustimov uh
knight c3 is
still possible and after e5
just to show you guys the whole idea
here
the uh bottom line here is that knight f
is the d5 is not good queen d1
king d1 knight g4 with a fork
and why could risk being worse here
and if knight d194 and white could risk
meaning worse here too
but according to alex knight f3 is the
best way to play here ed queen d4 and
white retains an edge in the end game
which i totally would believe
but nonetheless i feel like a lot of
players wouldn't want to get an end game
that quickly and i think black's got
good chances for equality there
so bishop d3 is the most accurate just
remember that
and g6 we go h3 bishop g7 i think this
is all very simple i think black is
playing well here this is fine
this is where our opponent started to go
off the ledge a little bit
i think the knight bdd knight b to d7
would be a more
uh accurate move i mean he's just
developing more actively he goes knight
f to d7
queen d2 preparing to trade the bishops
and c5 we go d5 c5 exacerbates the
situation now how can if black wanted to
avoid allowing the trade of bishops what
is the typical way of of
taking the sting out of bishop h6
yeah knight f3 before e4 is good too
rookie a rookie a bishop h6 bishop h a
but the thing is that even though you
preserved the bishop this is still very
passive why could like make a move such
as queen f4
white could simply bring the rook in
to d1 or e1 and we have just a
phenomenal position here
f3 interesting
so c5 d5 knight e55 we take it
now we play bishop h6 making him regret
the fact that he got his bishop away
from the pawn chain five bucks from
buddhazak
not in the business life now but let me
tell your videos have helped me a lot
with learning chess which is helping me
cope with everything thank you that's
very sweet
um that means a lot i hope you
get through everything uh and and thanks
a lot for that
so
why is what passive well he's not
developing his bishop is bad
we've got a monster center he's just
giving me all the good stuff
he's just giving me all the good stuff
so bishop g7 makes things even worse he
should have definitely kept his dark
squared bishop because this is really
the only piece that's holding black's
position together
and
no not necessarily decode there's no
rule that says that no it all depends on
the situation why is bishop h a passive
oh did i say that no no no i didn't mean
to suggest that this bishop is passive i
meant to suggest that black's entire
position is passive
i meant to suggest that black's entire
position is passive
in the sense that i mean just look at
how his pieces are all pushed to the
last two ranks that's all i really mean
i'm not
i don't mean to make a deep point here
um
this is just bad montana gifting to
budazak thank you
okay
so
queen d2 c5 d5 we take it we take it we
go rook id one and again how do i find
this move well i realized that his only
way of trying to cut into my
central superiority is to go e6
and in the event of e6
we can take on e6 and this rook is
perfectly positioned to x-ray his queen
now we can move our queen away from d2
and cause problems down the d file this
is the only open file
and when there is only one open file you
want to make sure that you are the one
controlling it when you are the one
controlling the only open file in the
position that is a huge positional
advantage
okay well the king's indian played
properly is not necessarily
uh an issue
why shouldn't black take the pun on d4
versus with the queen after white plays
bishop d3
uh no so queen d4 loses the queen you go
bishop b5 check and the queen is uh
toast knight c6 you can still take the
queen because the knight is pinned
okay so that's a that's an important
point
so a6 92 is a nice move
if b5 undefended pawn vulnerable king
fork grab the pawn and win the pawn
knight d7 at this point i don't even
care about b5
you know it's kind of like you're
you're attacking him from all sides and
this is like a gnat that you have to
brush off from your shoulder this is
just like a harmless move he's not doing
anything at all
and that's another thing which at this
level you have to be able to tell
yourself is
you have to be able to say
i see that my opponent has an idea but
i'm going to ignore it for one reason or
another
so catch yourself when you're
automatically trying to stop things that
aren't dangerous and try to always
figure out is my is my idea warrant
going for it immediately do i need to
waste the tempo on stopping my
opponent's idea if it's not dangerous
92-97 knight g3 our knight is poised to
sacrifice on f5 or h5
queen c7 and now it's time for the pawn
so e6 accelerates uh his demise for sure
but his position was essentially
untenable i mean
he probably should have gone for maybe
bring the king back to g8 or something
to that effect
and we would have gone
maybe rook f3 preparing a rook lift
queen c3 is good queen e3 just
centralizing the queen preparing f5 is
good there's a million different ideas
but black is not losing black is
you know a good player would be able to
hold hold on with black this is not the
game is not over white is overwhelmingly
better but
that's that's that is the bishop super
passive not really the bishop is not the
greatest bishop in the history of
bishops but so is his
and our bishop has a lot of prospects if
the position opens up the bishop will it
has a lot of potential energy this is a
classic example of a piece that has a
lot of potential energy if the this
diagonal opens the bishop might be
precisely the piece that's winning the
game first in fact the bishop was the
piece that won the game once he played
e6 check takes takes bishop c4
so again it's the same goes for white's
knight i think some of you are looking
at this position and saying
well i'm looking at the bishop it's
staring at its own pawn i'm looking at
the knight and i see the black's g-pawn
is two squares away from it and it's
limiting its control over these two
squares but you've got to see the bigger
picture here
we're going to rely on our pawns and our
queen and our rook
to open up the position and the moment
that it opens up sacrifices like knight
f5 become possible and this bishop uh is
perfectly positioned to attack so you've
got to see the big picture you've got to
see the
you got to play the longer game
and that's a little bit hard to do but i
hope i'm making some sense
so for example instead of f4 i was
considering queen g5
and that created the immediate threat of
knight f5 check and already the knight
is jumping into the game
and you know you could play e5 at some
point and open up the bishop too
so it's always a trade-off pieces can be
very active in the moment
but they can become very passive if the
position changes or the other way around
pieces could be not as active in the
time in the moment
but you could know for a
almost near certainty that you're going
to change the you're in control of the
situation so you are going to change the
position in a way that's going to make
the pieces more active
okay
how to get those pieces off the board
well again you can't guarantee that you
won't go wrong how many games have i
lost
because i've made a misjudgment i i
thought a piece would become active and
it doesn't
many you that's that but that's also
where the fun lies
you're able to test your judgment and if
you lose a game like that
you want to ask yourself well why did my
intuition go where did my intuition go
wrong what did i think what happened
that didn't happen why did i think it
would happen
you're exploring the root cause of your
misjudgment and that's how you can
improve your intuition so for example
you could say ah well i made this
observation i thought my opponent had to
do this and he didn't have to do it
so i'm going to try to make less
assumptions about what my opponent has
to do
it's hard to improve your intuition but
those are some things you could do to
try to improve your sort of judgment
judgment on the chessboard
okay so f4 e6 well what are the
indicators the indicator is that he's
we've removed his fiance bishop from the
board the question is you mentioned
potentially sacking the knight what were
the indicators for when a sacrifice
might be worth it so two things pattern
recognition
i've seen a million games with a
sacrifice like this it's super typical
uh in such situations super typical
uh in in in uh
in a you know in in positions where
um
where you've removed your opponent's
fiance bishop
and you've gotten the knight two to g3
this cracks open
the
pawn structure on the king so for
example
just in the last two seconds i came up
with the game here
which really typical which really shows
this well
um and this is quite the
quite the set of players just one second
guys
so for example we have a position here
uh sultan khan against vera manchik the
first women's world champion sultan khan
very famous player in his own right so
watch what happens in the next couple of
moves bishop takes h6 mantric takes on
c4 boom boom and guess what move sultan
khan plays it's the proximity of the
knight in the king that kills black here
knight f5 track comes in montana gifting
the dragon queen and if g takes f5 you
go check
you win back the knight and look at how
weak the king is so bishop takes f5
happens but now
the f5 pawn acts as a battering ram you
shatter the defenses around black's king
and sultan khan goes on basically to
deliver checkmate and he defends for a
while
but then he eventually crashes through
and wins thank you for the 100.
so
you know when you look at these games
you develop the pattern recognition the
sense for these tactics and you know
imagine having seen
30 games like that that's the first
thing you'd be thinking about when you
when you saw this position
okay so
here here here here and this is very
simple now the other last thing i'll say
is that d6 was a possibility as well the
idea is to
lure the queen
into a discovery and then you go bishop
e5 winning the game you win the piece
um
and black can't even give away the queen
for for a rook and a piece because the
knight is going to be hanging anyway
but i decided to open up the position
this is just more overwhelming because
black doesn't have to take the pawn on
d6 boom boom boom
and f5 ends the game on the spot
some of you were indicating knight f5 as
a possibility
threatening checkmate sacking the knight
and then perhaps going rook f3 trying to
lift the rocket and deliver checkmate
and maybe that's winning but i feel like
at this particular moment
i um
you know i i decided to play less
adventurously you know sometimes you
want to weigh the pros and cons if
you're absolutely sure that the pretty
move wins go ahead and play it but
sometimes you want to prioritize you
know business
business first you want to win the game
as one australian i am said i like to
quote this um
you play in tournaments to win points
not to paint pictures and at the end of
the day that's true
uh the you know winning the game you
play to win the game so rook d7 in the
game is over king h8 rook d7 would have
also been
game over yes he's completely
overwhelmed
and that was the game guys this was a
nice one so we're over 1700
the 10 minute speed run we will probably
go until about 2 300 because
10 minute chess is just not very common
over 2000
and so we'll probably stop when we hit
2300 and
at that point you know we'll go on to
the next project
and uh i'm
you know i'm still deciding what that's
going to be but it's been awesome to be
to do the speed note so far i think it's
gone really really well i su i really
appreciate people's engagement
it it brings this to a whole other level
[Music]